what do you think is the best strategy
to Foster the love of Science and
curiosity in a young person get out of
her way oh wow look at that yeah we
spend the first years of their life
teaching them to walk and talk and then
we spend the rest of their lives telling
them to shut up and sit down children
are born curious get out of their way
that Curiosity will be maintained until
the day arise when you squash it watch
what they do if they reach for a an egg
what do you typically say at that point
no no
no no yeah no no put the egg down you
might break it when you could let the
kid have the egg and you know it's going
to break but then they're going to see
what's inside the egg right and there's
like the albumin and the Yol you then
you tell them that might have been a
chicken right that that'll freak them
out right there and then they and then
they become vegan and that's how you
make a
vegan plus they learn that something
could be hard yet fragile right